[Music]
the outsiders ravage our lands
their cruelty to my people is all i've
known
so you're going tomorrow yes i'm going
tomorrow to advance in i'd like you to
take me with you
are you trying to give me corn marshall
can i trust you something
i've been having dreams about a girl
falling in battle
felt like a vision
dreams make good stories but everything
important happens when we're awake
to the future of house of treaties
you have to be ready
there is no call we do not answer there
is no faith that we betray
they're not human they're
if i'm not brutal
you'll still be the only thing i ever
needed you to beat come on
listen
i know you
tonight the bloodline ends forever
kill them all
this is an extermination
they're picking my family off one by one
only together
[Music]
can we stand a chance let's fight like
demons
it's not safe for you here
i must not fear
fear is the mind killer
the fear is gone
homie will remain
[Music]
this is only the beginning
remember that story that they told us
about in training
about george washington's first female
spy during the revolution
they called her agent 355
because they didn't want the world to
know her real name
but her legacy lives on
[Music]
we're the top agents from around the
world american
british
german colombian chinese
but now we have a common enemy
they can start world war three
from simple reach of their keyboard so
we need to join forces
it's like half the cia's most wanted
always such a tough guy
i'm not an agent i'm a therapist they
thought i would give you my secrets do
you have secrets
we put ourselves in danger so that
others are not
i'll handle the guns
are you in therapy i should be you're
the best in the world of what you do you
have cameras in your jewelry comes in
your earrings you bump i grab
the target is on the move
you're not going in there alone we go
together
i have a family i cannot do this anymore
the bad guys are out there right now
you go home
you bring them with you
are you under control are you no
black cars all black
but thanks for the
i like the tip team we're the 355.
[Music]
every story has a beginning
discover the origin of evil
[Music]
why are you back here claire your
conspiracies weren't true when we were
kids they're not true now
we need to expose umbrella
watch this
i'm afraid claire i'm afraid of what
they're gonna do to this town
you see umbrella they have an incident
i'm talking chernobyl if you know what i
mean
people are getting sick
you gotta help us claire let the world
know what's really going on
[Music]
shall
[Music]
[Music]
high
[Music]
we're gonna take umbrella
what's
down
on
[Music]
once there was a place in the woods
where they sent people who didn't fit
into the real world welcome jacob
species identity disorder can be cured
so that a person who thinks themselves
an animal
can resume a happy healthy
and rewarding life i want to do it it's
the best thing for everyone
[Music]
you're all gonna end up wonderful human
beings
they say the wolf and the wildcat are
natural enemies
but they're wrong
how long have you been here
since i can remember
i'm putting you out
you call him a zookeeper
keep clear of him
everything running away only one person
ever did
i've always had this feeling
these instincts
[Music]
once upon a time
there was a wolf
and a wild cat
i wanted to live happily ever after
it's not just about surviving but
surviving is
me do you really think you can have a
life with that boy
[Music]
but life is no fairy tale
is it
[Music]
do you want things to get worse for you
i have no human form i have no human
form
jacob
what have they done to you
[Music]
all right whenever you're ready
we are shooting a documentary because i
am about to meet my first biological
relative
she's amish i'm not i am not
we are humbled and grateful to have our
sister margot return to us
i've always hoped that i could meet you
all so this is a really special moment
for me
hey
mind if i film you for a moment
uh oh hey
[Music]
i like your doll
what's her name
yeah
you know that was my mom's name
she used to live here a long time ago
she's still here
[Music]
what did she say
[Music]
wow
why would they build a church all the
way back here
what is that the demon asmodeus was
trapped inside a chosen woman of god
this has happened before
what the hell
are these from my mom
you can't have me and my baby
[Applause]
i know every i was family within a
50-mile area
they have faint amish
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh my god are you sure about this
i have to know
uh
[Music]
what can i say fellas when i leave
you'll be missed
[Applause]
beautiful
will
olga
let me hold you
you go first
[Music]
attention attention dear comrades the
people city council informs you that due
to an incident at the turnover nuclear
power plant there is an adverse
radioactive situation in the city of
privia
[Music]
the reactor is in a sub-critical state
as you all know enough fuel burns
through and gets to the water there will
be a steam explosion full of radioactive
material the contamination of
uncontained will spread to kiev moscow
and all of western europe
right so we have to get the water out
the volunteers will receive payment
[Music]
we're talking dirty water in a confined
space not a clean swimming pool all your
engineers just won't cut it
i'm going back down you won't survive
again
we have no authority to order it
do you really want to risk the citizens
of kiev getting ready for the mayday
celebration
in
[Music]
in five weeks a hundred thousand british
forces will strike sicily southern shore
unfortunately the nazis know of our
intentions
so we're going to play a humiliating
trick on hitler
[Applause]
we have to convince germany that our
target is greece the plan begins in
spain where the corpse will wash up on
shore bearing classified letters
a corpse carrying fake documents
giving the fascist network there we
could quite literally float the
documents right into enemy hands
prime minister that's too big a risk the
fate of the world is at stake the plan
is highly implausible
so when can it be ready
well let's say we start with the easy
part and find ourselves a corpse
i think is the germans will scrutinize
every detail of our fallen man
where are his legs
he must be as real as your eye he would
carry a letter from his wife professing
her deep love for him very good
and he would carry her photograph my
contribution to the mission for a seat
at the table
although
what if the autopsy reveals he didn't
die of drowning
or if the briefcase is returned to us
without the germans seeing its contents
charles why on earth do you keep poking
holes in our plan i'm preemptively
poking
success depends
on guiding the papers into hitler's
hands
the nightmare marching this way is only
too real in the spanish we play the
germans anywhere near our briefcase we
are in the dark
if the enemy is waiting for us on those
beaches
history herself will avert our eyes from
the slaughter
i may vomit
i may vomit with you
in stories of war there is that which is
seen and that which is hidden
[Music]
in god's name fleming what are you
writing
spy story
in the hidden war the truth
is protected by a bodyguard of lies
its soldiers unseen
prey its heroes unsung
this
is our war
[Music]
it's a god awful small affair
[Music]
listen young lady but a
[Music]
yeah do you know who my girlfriend is
rubbish
barbra streisand
sand yeah like sands like the ocean like
oversized sand
no but stray sand sand
but the film is
[Music]
do you really want to see my boobs
can i touch them
see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
i think it's weird that i hang out with
gary and his 15 year old friends all the
time
[Music]
just like you're not gonna forget me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
action
[Music]
[Music]
many years ago
this candle blessed our family with a
miracle
our house our casita came to life with
magic
[Music]
drawers
[Music]
i'm not super strong like lisa the
donkeys got out again
or effortlessly perfect like
perfect
but my mom
why am i the only one that didn't get a
gift you're just as special as anyone
else in this family
you just healed my hand with the nade
pacon queso
casita
what's going on
the magic is in danger we gotta get out
of here we must protect our home we must
protect our family
this is my chance i will save the magic
wait
how do i save the magic
i'm losing my gift
[Music]
the fate of the family
it's gonna come down to you i can't do
this let me help you
the rats told me everything don't eat
those
even in our darkest moments
there's
[Music]
but at least i'll have a friend nope you
flew away immediately quitter
[Music]
pleasure to meet you sarah de bergerac
you're a freak
freak
[Music]
my dearest friend be very angry with you
if you died
my sole purpose on this earth is to love
roxanne does she know the world will
never accept someone like me and a tall
beautiful woman
we have no money a clever marriage is
your only option i won't be rescued i'm
not in distress love does that mean
nothing to you children need love adults
need money
i need something to die for
write bones and cry for and i won't be
ashamed
i'd give anything
for someone to say
that they can't live without me and
they'll be
i have a confession to make i am madly
in love perhaps he feels the same but
i've never actually spoken to him of
your love i think
he is christian christian
he's a new recruit you're a regiment of
course he is a woman like roxanne wants
wit romance poetry i don't know how to
speak romantically i am a poet my words
upon your lips
i will make you romantic will you make
me handsome she loves me
for someone to say
[Music]
[Applause]
speak to me like you do in your letters
you are a beautiful flower i am not a
flower i need more
we must let her decide our fate she must
have the choice
[Music]
will you renfield take this woman
what is that girl doing here she's some
sort of monster hunter
your new targets are messy the loch ness
monster and yeti
the snow monster of the himalayas we
have to stop her max no prepare me for
the fight mom he's gonna turn us all
into monsters again on this magical
monster night
great job max but how can we save them
if we don't know where they are i can
find anyone with this party people
disappear
[Music]
faster and stronger
it's not too late to change your mind
[Music]
don't worry i've got you
i'm so glad no one knows me out here
you are all crazy
okay that's not good
you can't see anything
i will transform a bat into a handsome
prince
[Music]
emergency at the chemical factory
georgia girls aren't allowed to be
firemen but i'm as brave as any boy
it's my dream it's my destiny
girls can't be firemen give me a break
extra arsonist breaks again
firemen who go into the theaters
they don't come out
i need you to run the fire investigation
i'll need a team here's the plan i
joined dad's team egg crate for the
stomach muscles mango for the biceps
and for the mustache
[Music]
okay too much
[Music]
let me introduce you the brains of your
operation ricardo
uh ginger driver fastest cabbie in
manhattan
who are you me uh i'm joe i'm fireman
joe slow down joe did you even check
the water
it's funny
you remind me of my daughter really yeah
that is funny
yeah she wanted to be a fireman too
so why didn't you teach her what you're
teaching me she's my daughter i love her
and i worry about her every second of my
life
i catch the arsonist i'll have to change
the rules then i'll be the first fireman
woman the job is far too dangerous
maybe this is a sign that it's time you
follow your own dreams
i never gave up on mine
[Music]
the mustache is very convincing it's my
dog's butt hair
[Music]